gang just want to remind you that the ru
garbage comedy special is on our youtube
page right now it is it is our favorite
moments from last year's tour and
speaking of doors we're here to announce
2022 the middle class famous store baby
new cities new trash new money yeah gang
we're coming to hartford albany syracuse
atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh buffalo
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago rosemont and this is just part
one plenty of cities coming after that
it's live stand up live auig it's a good
time get your tickets now we'll see you
there welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out if they grow
up to be classy or to just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host stage foley
coming at you on a beautiful day down
here in antoni's basement she's outside
just set up a lemonade stand
just lean but still
she's trying selling scissors my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
he is the ceo of are you garbage he's
international man of business and
mystery
sexuality yeah we like it give it up for
kj
can't be kevin james ryan hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you view subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true
thank you and then obviously the
greatest website of all time patreon.com
are you garbage sweet lord we're about a
hundred and so patrons away from our
next goal which is taking the big man to
disney world first i mean epcot yeah i
want a big lolly and some mickey ears
drinking around the world so check it
out uh how about a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the magic
man the brains behind the are you
garbage special uh-huh it's on youtube
right now you got to check it out give
it up for tebow mcmuffin toby mcmullen
what's up dudes
i wouldn't say i'm the
full brains we got a big-headed man
sitting at that table who also
contributed quite a bit
i had 104 fever at the time so i don't
know
i didn't even know if you were on the
other line of the phone
gang we could not and i mean could not
be more excited to have our incredibly
special guest back with us again today
if you haven't seen this episode you got
to go back and check it out one of the
funniest stand-up comedians out there
right now he has a brand new album out
right now called king scorpio and he's
going to be filming his first official
special february 3rd down there in new
orleans
at tippatina's doing two shows a seven
and a nine real classy you can get some
ticks at me sean patton.com do me a
favor give me a nice put down what you
have in front of you put the kids to the
side for a second stop making dinner and
give me a nice big round of applause for
mr sean patton everybody come on
he's one of the best thank you personal
favorite personal
ours you know what i want i want there
to be i want to can i thank you thank
you guys for having me back by the way
of course first and foremost nice to
meet you toby i don't think i think you
were i think you were uh last time i was
on it was not toby it wasn't it was he
wasn't born yet it was just he was not
alive yet toby toby was still in the
test tube
elon musk was making him somewhere right
but i'm trying to figure out his battery
there should be a patreon uh tier where
if you guys get to it you guys will read
any bedtime story okay
because the the two of you together oh
yeah yeah yeah reading any bedtime story
listen kids all right listen what you
want to do is you want to go down there
the problem with the doors there were
seven of them but only four of was union
i didn't understand
so hey come here
sleeping in their bed they're out of
work all day they come back she didn't
make dinner or not
and she's got her grandmom's come
looking for and the [__] horses start
coming now they're coming with [__]
axes and pitchforks for us yeah
anyway
and but they got the security system
right
and that costs an arm and a freaking leg
there i can't i can't do the [__] i feel
like i have the philly accent for like
one sentence and then it just i lose it
too yeah falls off not you have you
actually you don't
i don't think you'll ever lose i don't
think
oh no you're like yeah you're like
jordan with a jump shot yeah go you can
wake you up in the dead sleeping in a
three
i'm sorry i'm sorry allen iverson yes
with the crossover yes let me remember
who i'm talking to
talking too
[Laughter]
yeah this uh it's i i that's good it's
good to be back good here because i like
uh i like this podcast because i like it
what you guys did after the last time i
did it was it made me really examine my
life
we get that a lot yeah you look inward a
lot you look inward and you're like wait
a second though what and then you start
to flip it around and be like wait a
second is garbage just what we're told
by the [__] one percent
yeah
they do it too who say this is a bad
thing to be when in reality it's we're
the beautiful everyone's got blood on
our heads yes we are the beautiful the
garbage is the beautiful mm-hmm with
that without a doubt now there's lines
that slip and they fall and they cross
and it gets a little dicey and stuff
like that but for the most part it's
good to be garbage you can't have
garbage without a good time yes it's a
good [__] time yeah good garbage nice
box of wine bad garbage leaving your
cigarette out in front of the 7-eleven
when you go in to get a taquito right
right they come out and rip into good
garbage you know some empty condom
wrappers
you know uh it's a good time even if
you're by yourself that's a dress you
know what i mean uh you know bad time uh
a bad garbage you know aborted fetus
like a trash can yeah yeah
i don't know did you guys did you guys
my first experience with a condom
definitely wasn't with a woman no i
definitely tried there was definitely
there was definitely some dress
rehearsals yeah i don't trust i don't
trust anyone who's first time with a
condom was with a woman how would you
know what the yeah you had to figure it
out on your own when i was a kid i when
we talk about like little league about
condoms and rubbers i thought it was
like
robbers is it
yeah doctors i think doctors call them
rubber
hey kid you got rubbers on you
i think they actually were originally
trademarked as rubber uppers
rubbers is tough rubbers is not a that
makes me weird you got your rubbers on
you yeah you got a rubbish right wait
what was another rubbers uh uh jimmy's
jimmy jimmy's jimmy's is bad too jimmy's
was a i mean i got to tell you right now
the first my first ever exp this will i
if i didn't say this on the last podcast
this was in a
one of the first things i ever stole was
a box of condoms
really right and i and i masturbated
into each and every one of them it was
like it was an eight-day trial period
i'm just like
doing it again you returned them didn't
like it
[Laughter]
i fell asleep right after this uh
you know i was 14. it was very
lubricating though when you put it on
for the first time you're like oh wait a
minute it's okay i don't need the broad
dude
it's almost like i'm saving this itself
sure
yeah
ripped for my pleasure
the moment you put it on you're just
like wait this is just the protection uh
yeah well it's this is gonna be
awesome it's a person
what's it protecting me from
or being more awesome yeah well it's the
first time you have like a new sensation
as like whatever a 14 year old or
whatever you know what i mean instead of
just like some lube or conditioner in
the
shower thing as well you ever make the
mistake and go shampoo
shower yeah sure yeah catch a steak i
did a dishwasher so palm olive and then
left it on there like an idiot and my
skin peeled like i was [__]
it was bad it was like hiroshima down
there it was tough
screaming in the streets i remember
using a [__] you ever you remember
when i mean i don't think this is an age
specific thing but it happened a lot
more when you're younger when you just
go on a masturbation tear yeah like
specifically the first time you ever saw
internet porn you're like this is just
free
and unlimited and thumbnails yeah i
remember being 20 years old just going
on a [__] tear but i was using prell
right chambray oh yeah uh you know
that's the tough stuff the hearts yeah
wait trying to get the curls out what
are you doing
i just wasn't i just hadn't put two and
two together that way were you in the
shower or no you were out i was outside
of the shower using champagne
because it was just this guy plays by
his own bad move but it ruined it ruined
my unit for like three or four three to
five days
it was just a it was you know what i
mean it was like i was a burn victim
you know
and uh and i and it was the only time
i've ever had a great bounce though i'll
tell you that oh yeah yeah
what a lot of volume smell smell like
springtime
but i actually missed the chance to
actually hook up with a woman because of
that because it was all banged up
yeah irony right there yeah yeah yeah
treating yourself like an amusement park
i think that was a charles that was
charles dickens example
of irony itself
or or uh activity and consequence on a
fortnight i was masturbating with prowl
that's dude to masturbate on a couch or
a computer chair computer chair with
shampoo that's crazy that's crazy to me
it was it was the one it's got to get
everywhere there was no lotion in the
house there was no lotion uh i had used
the conditioner was done and in my head
i was just like
you know yeah the condition i broke up
the week before yeah let me just say
this bottle conditioner was done and
never once did i use it in my hair
[Laughter]
uh but yeah like i was like whatever
same thing same difference conditioner
is the hardest you go yeah don't you
don't go shampoo yeah don't go soap
especially in the not some herbal
essence or something back in the 90s
early 2000s herbal essence is the
lightest you would want to go
but yeah i'm sorry if you did shampoo
herbal essence shampoo was very very
organic very clean oh yeah dude the goat
for years was pam just ch pam
you would use pam corking spray on your
unit what are you working at
crazy benihana just it's one spray and
the lubrication factors just
it's you know because the heat
it's the heat it's built for heat it's
built to withstand heat plus the eggs
don't stick
slipping all over the place exactly
why would they give it a lady's name if
they didn't when we took off with it
called pete you know what i mean
[Laughter]
seductive pam there you go holy [__]
oh yeah damn now you bringing that into
the room
and hold on is this as a kid
i mean so you're operating behind enemy
lines you're not sneaking down to the
pantry in the middle of the night
and then running back up well my my my
like best friend growing up had like a
garage room with a foosball table in it
and a couch so we would all you know
three cases of pampers well well pam to
lube up the uh
the the foosball rods ah okay and one of
these nights when we were drunk hammered
and i was you know and everybody people
had gone into the house and i was i'm
like i'm just gonna crash in here on the
couch and they were they were nudi mags
and i was like i made it [__] it
loops up the foosball rods i get it in
theory it does make sense it's pretty
close to using wd-40 yeah it is it is it
is you're really close to jerking off
with caulk yeah you got the gun
just give me a minute give me a minute
check it off with window [__] like a
scumbag there you go bro ouch i'm sick
i'm serious no i mean dude pam is and
it's and it's you it's like olive oil
base you know olive oil is all right
alveolar pinch of wolves all right when
you want to feel mediterranean yeah yeah
yeah when you want to feel
when you want to feel exotic yeah
but not dude yeah pam i i highly
recommend it for the for the kids
listening
don't do that
just a little spray on the hand don't
bring it in your bedroom because what's
going to happen is your mom's going to
find it in your bedroom
yeah yourself out of part of i remember
trying yeah i love i love chef ramsay or
whatever like what the [__] you going to
say one time
my mom found a can she was like why was
this by the computer desk and i said
exactly damn yeah because i was like
because i had to lube up the chair i was
like the chair was not bad at a [__] and
i got away it was like one of those like
okay that was the one that was the one
time i get away with that you know what
i mean yeah yeah you flew too close to
this all of a sudden you're mr fisk fix
it around the house
squeaky
my sister got grounded and had to clean
the entire [__] house for a week once
and she found it in my bathroom
and was like why was this in your
bathroom and i did the same thing with
the toilet seat i was like the toilet
seat was squeaking and it worked with
her so
your mom wasn't around my mom wasn't
around cause she'd have been like oh
wait a second yeah why are why are you
sitting all these squeaky seats sean
because i jerk off at him
i'm sorry oh should've been like my
little sean's very handy
very handy i mean i imagine that's got
to be a moment every father goes through
with their son where you realize all the
moments that they're just jerking off
wailing all night i feel like i was
pretty good i got away pretty clean
i don't think i ever really got caught
there might have been some suspicion
there was something with like the
browser history on the family computer
some questionable yeah
that got brought in front of you know a
jury of my peers but yeah nothing that
could be turned into
no no
no no eyewitness testimony no
hearsay it's it's lubric it's lubricant
extraordinaire i was i was i did a lot
of dry work myself you know i wasn't
lubing all the time god yeah
naturalistic he's got a natural oily
natural sheen that's a superpower it
secretes out of his hand it's real dry
it's real dry it's jesus that would be
like a brick layer like the rough stuff
huh
somebody yanking pulling my own hair
somebody grab it at you i love the idea
of just the awful version of spider-man
you get bit by a radioactive stripper
and you could squirt you could squirt
lube out of your hand
i'll be right back everybody runs off
comes back five minutes later dude
that's that's wild yeah i mean but i
mean like do you guys have kids
no
that's what that's what i'm wondering
about father's just having to be like
well he's taking another shower huh yeah
45 minute shower they gotta know at some
point you know they they you have to
there's no way a guy i feel there's no
way a guy can masturbate in my house and
me not know i think i think i think
challenge accepted
what are you doing later
i'm not sure sean's uh religious
background but as a catholic
we were always taught that we were
operating behind enemy lines anyway yeah
right
there was an eye in the sky it's like a
casino yeah so i was never like it
wasn't like a discovery thing like oh
[__] i could do this and it was always
under wraps in the in in the wee hours
of the evening so
the cover of darkness i would say i was
like okay were you raised catholic were
you raised were were your parents like
hardcore catholic or more like social
catholic ah a little bit of both i was
going to hell if i was jerking off if
that's what you're saying oh okay i was
on the fast train we were more just like
social because all the good schools in
louisiana are catholic schools where
[__] money and resources are and so
all the good teachers eventually get
pulled so we all everybody went to
catholic school when i was coming up and
uh my parents were not religious but
they were very like you obey the god and
then they'd go smoke weed and
be there that you know be deviant as
well but lent lent
two years two years in a row i gave up
drinking all four languages really but i
remember other tell anybody that i don't
believe in god that much well under that
under lent rules sunday was all
sunday was on sunday's fair game sunday
you could do whatever you want the thing
you gave up you could do only on sundays
wow we didn't have that no it was 40
days straight through oh no dude we have
no i couldn't sneak a kick out on a
sunday oh probably there's no meet on
friday and and yeah it was why he were
locked in was the worst 40 days ever
because i never completed it i always
felt like an [__] all my cousins
cousins would knock it out they would
give up this that like five things i
never played that i never even attempted
they like what do you give and like
but they ask you that in school like
sean what are you gonna give it up you
didn't tell some none i'm gonna give up
slapping the ham
you say chocolate or something no of
course yeah of course i said video games
[__] like that but in my head it was
like i'm just not gonna whack off yeah
and on sundays you'd be like i'm only
cause all i'm doing my parents must have
thought i was meditating
you know that's sean loves religion he's
just he's in there you know connecting
to his to the lord
well yeah dude i mean every time they
open the door you got a rosary in your
hand
kneeling next to your bed it's like is
that a real oh no that's just his
exhausted [__]
yoinked all of the spirit out of it
oh my god buddy thank you so much for
coming in and sitting with us so that
was just the intro yeah
yeah uh you guys knows as you sign up
for patreon we'll ask your questions on
the air
um
and we're gonna do that right now
how are you garbage after a word from
these sponsors uh this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp yes folks are
you hanging on by a thin thread out
there are you losing it sure we all are
i am right now certain bald guy that's
my trigger right there i hit the sauce
more than usual sure what of it better
help can help you if you have something
that's standing away from your happiness
you have something that you're dragging
around talk to somebody get it out i
started therapy it's fantastic better
help can help especially if you're in
the areas where you can't find your
specialist they have specialists on call
that can help you yes guys it's not a
crisis line it's not a self-help line
it's professional therapy done securely
online everybody's talking to someone
you gotta talk to someone it's not taboo
anymore it's not weird you're not
talking about the feds either keep your
mouth shut yeah when it comes to that
mum's the word but talk to a therapist
if you need it everybody can find you
know the benefits of talking to a
therapist a special offer for are you
guard resistance you get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com garbage
one more time that's betterhelp.com
garbage do it let's talk about athletic
greens ag-1 ag-1 as an athlete myself of
course i am on the ag-1 i saw the ads on
instagram yeah a few months ago turns
out bam they become a sponsor they send
us some i haven't looked back i've had
it every day yeah all right
great nutrition
vitamins like a super multivitamin gut
health immunity and it gives you a
little energy if you feel good i'm off
the coffee i'm done coffee and i tell
you what else i know what's that i was
drinking it after my workouts for a
while since i've had it
yesterday when i got done i was drinking
it during the workout and i'm telling
you i felt better yes i'm telling you
it's what it's for it's fantastic it
does everything uh it's lifestyle
friendly whether you're keto paleo vegan
dairy-free gluten-free whatever contains
less than one gram of sugar no gmos no
nasty chemicals or artificial anything
and it still tastes good we're talking
about pure stuff here it tastes great
and you put it on something
put it with some cold water in your
thing and shake it up you look cool
drinking it feel cool it has a very tony
stark kind of vibe too it does yeah uh
it supports better sleep quality and
recovery supports mental clarity
alertness the whole nine yards you got
to get involved with this stuff over
seven thousand five star reviews uh
recommended by professional athletes
trusted by leading health experts such
as tim ferriss and michael gervais well
guess who else uses it every day my
trainer
says it's hitting hard everybody
good stuff right now it's time to
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
your trainer's getting cut out of this
especially heading into i'm choking into
the fluency frozen like he owed you
money just one scoop in a cup of water
every day that's it no need for a
million different pills or supplements
to look out for your health take it easy
athletic grains is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit athletic
greens.com garbage again that is
athleticgreens.com to take ownership of
your health and pick up the ultimate
daily nutritional insurance do it yeah
this is in the first this is in the the
realm and i thought this one was a
little harsh but we're in here this is
from bryce
um i haven't had one read yet have you
ever used anything besides a condom as a
condom
wow
no i mean i
no have you i don't know
no i think people do that yes i think
it's more common than we would think i
mean i guess by that rationale i've used
the atmosphere as a condom because i've
definitely pulled out [__]
i mean i have i did have sex with a
couple barren women so i used they were
their own condoms
i flew close to the sun a couple of
times
that's funny
i feel like i have
in some depraved moment at some point
there was an attempt
i don't know if it ever followed ziploc
bag or something i i remember i remember
definitely sizing something like a
little peter in the corner there was a
rummaging through the kitchen through
the cabinets or something i mean someone
had to at some point i think i think the
first condom i think it's common
practice in a lot of places
yeah like it's like the first ever
condom ever like the first ever condom
it was like beer or a sandwich it was an
accident yeah yeah the first condom was
a condom yeah yeah it was like lamb it
was like a lamb
oh that's right yeah it was lamb
intestines yeah that's what they used
yeah they still have those lambs
i don't think that's real lambskin well
maybe not it was like a welsh heathen
who banged the sheep yeah and then we
pulled out didn't realize that he popped
the [__]
anal vestige off with him and then went
home and made love to his light wife
and then pulled i was like holy holy
[__] it's [__] still here
it captured it
i should share this with the scientists
in the village this is the terror what
[__] action is that i can't do
accents really i feel like i started go
with the scottish for a second it's a
scott i say i'm living in wales
i'm from edinburgh originally but i
don't live in wales where they got the
good ship
that's not bad that's good better to me
but that's just accusing all uh that's a
big hack comedian thing in england
is like oh you're from wales how many
sheep do you [__] sure yeah like a
constant like the rednecks here right
right like even like as a non-welsh
person whenever i've been in england and
a comedian goes into that i'm like lay
off the welsh
give them a break yeah yeah that
cardiff's a good city what's wrong with
the sheep yeah and what are they doing
why are you judging the sheep have you
kevin
no oh no never no have you ever used two
of those little rappers they put like
little buttons in well hershey kiss
wrapper
no no that and they always said don't
use two condoms because
i've used two condoms before they say
that's worse because it creates friction
and easier to pop keeps you in the game
longer though hate to tell you wow
sometimes i need it i should use four or
five man
i'm still undefeated
well they have that they have that you
could that you could run the cream you
could not make like numbing cream
just what they said [__] just read raid
from the below
put a little ambassador in the hill no
just a bug spray just put a little bug
spray on there
[Laughter]
all right let's see this one's from uh
matthew ever substitute water for
windshield washer fluid yeah dude yeah
all the time i mean i mean i actually
that questions phrase wrong have ever
used with children
instead of water yeah
well for us because it freezes that was
so that was the big thing you couldn't
you had to use water but the water had
to be out of there
by [__] mixture a little bit yeah mix
it wait wait hey wait [__] wait here's a
ask me that question again here's what i
should have said you ever substitute
water for windshield washer fluid every
time i think about killing myself
i just hydrate instead yeah instead of
drinking too dark
that stuff looks like [__]
rush gatorade yeah it looks like it
tastes pretty good
dude i've thought dude antifreeze no
it's too it looks like it would kill you
what what movie am i thinking of where
he where they drink
windex
by accidents like an alien that drinks
windex by accident they're like no but
you're not supposed to be doing that
sounds very alfish yeah and he burps
like a bubble ah [__] but
it does look good i can see it right
next with some crushed ice be all right
i mean windex looks all right
yeah that's why there's the spanish uh
fabuloso
they had to switch up their packaging i
remember i saw that
23rd street yeah it is kind of been like
delicious it's in like a beverage it
used to be like a beverage it's like a
20 ounce beverage package yeah what are
you selling in a six pack for you
trying to kill it why does it come with
a straw
why does it come with a straw is it a
juice box pot
i mean that's i've definitely done that
for i don't 100 100 i've done it with
water
i believe i've done it with water and
for antifreeze
yes antifreeze 100 you just put water in
the tank so they used to pee in the tank
back in the day when the when the
coppers were chasing you
you pee in the tank you could pee in
your it just needs fluid it doesn't have
to be antifreeze antifreezes if you live
in a cold wall like you get back to the
hideout if you got to bust a radio yeah
if you're jammed up yeah it's like
putting a donut on yeah you pee into the
radiator and [__] keep it moving
get somebody on the tommy gun hang it on
the back
that makes sense yeah what was your
first car
1987 lincoln continental
my body yeah how many girls were in the
stable at the time
dude
that the stinking lincoln baby that
thing was badass um
like i mean they only came in this one
like groot like a gray blue yes yeah
yeah double double tone two tone cone
that [__] was bad i mean it was in
1997. she was like 10 years old it was
like a decade old it was my aunt's car
that she just
didn't drive anymore so like we've got
we bought it from her for cheap as [__]
but that thing i mean power everything
yeah like seats but it was like i also i
was also a driver power drive there was
an ashtray for sure in the back seat too
oh yeah on the doors yeah yeah you're
talking about that in liberty yeah old
literary cabs having the
uh ashtrays on the doors you ever get on
a plane that still has yeah man and
you're going how [__] old is this
yeah like should i be on this [__]
old but they're like it's a flight to
boston
it's a short flight on the way back from
france there was an ashtray in the
bathroom there was a clean metal ashtray
in the bathroom like on the door have
you wait no one in this room is old
enough to have ever been on a flight
when smoking no that's what i'm saying
yeah i think i might have been but were
you like super were you like a kid
uh could you smoke on airplanes in 1989
that was the first time i took it
definitely i think it was up until the
late i think it was up until this
century
there was a smoking section i think
there was a smoke on the plane
i mean 89 toby no way smoking was banned
on planes in 1988 yeah what that early
yeah [__] dude
i remember okay because i remember
smoking sections at restaurants oh [__]
smoking or not we were a smoking section
that was until like 99. yeah yeah that
you think 99 around there i remember new
york about that time it was maybe 99
2001 2002 well new york had some hot i
remember new york being like because
when i moved here in 2007 and new york
was already deep into like no smoking
inside and for a time in the in the arts
it was no smoking right outside the
entrance yeah yeah like you would get in
trouble yeah yeah or shout it out if
you're just the doorman comes out starts
busting your balls i remember in philly
you heard that new york did that like
you can't even smoke on the street you
believe that i'm never gonna live there
that calmy [__] city dude i did i did
a show in philly once and i i can't
remember where it was because we got
they got us so hammered before the show
but it was like this theater it was this
act it was this like thespian bar
yes yeah
no no that's a that's a that's a
writer's bar it was called like the
player's theater something like that but
like the bar afterwards they were just
like light them up dude yeah yeah and
it's like a social club
i know what you're talking about it was
all the way at the top floor yeah the
bar was yeah i know exactly but new in
new orleans you could smoke in bars
still up until maybe three like 2017-ish
maybe yeah
so like that was when i quit smoking in
2016 but like going back in like
back when i was like a hardcore smoker
going home and just being like in the
smoking in the bar was
[__] heaven
i don't give a [__] it was heaven yeah
it was the best you just ripped through
a pack and a half an american the pack
and the lighter sitting on the ball wow
i miss it i haven't smoked a cigarette
in five years and i never will again
because i've like i i don't know if you
got you guys ever smoke we yeah we were
smoking when you walked up outside oh
[__] you still smokers i quit for five
and a half years but um okay when you
quit though did you quit as like i
should quit or like uh i should quit it
was like i wanted to yeah it was like 15
years in or whatever when i quit i had
been smoking for 15 years i got i got to
give this okay
so because but but i guess you have a
freakout yeah i had i got to a point
where every time i smoked a cigarette
like my heart would get crazy my heart
would beat crazy really i kind of got
that going yeah every morning i would
cough like insane amounts of just smoke
or [__]
that was what i was paying for yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but yeah like my body was basically like
we're about to go on strike yeah that
was kind of there yeah i was kind of
there what i wanted to say is i know
it's from being around smokers when i
was a kid yeah
but there was a certain situation where
you were like the right amount of hungry
the certain kind of hungry the place
served a certain kind of food maybe like
some mozzarella sticks a burger those
kind of things and it was like a bar
restaurant where not sitting in the
smoking session but sitting in the
non-smoking section but you got a little
bit of the space
yeah yeah
really really filled out the meal yeah
yeah really really dead dude we would if
we cherry coke in front of you or
shirley temple if they didn't have
smoking section we would go somewhere
else my dad be like ah now we're not
going like he couldn't in hindsight you
couldn't make it 90 minutes without
smoking oh yeah proper [__] smoking
section when i think about when i think
like i started smoking because my
grandma
like we would like for years it was like
we'd go to her house after school from
when i was in like
pre-kindergarten to maybe sixth grade
yeah and she would just be ripping down
paul malls indoors
and she would have to i would get there
first and then she would have to go
i'd be alone at her house for like 45
minutes and i would just
rip down a palm mall and she'd have no
clue really i was like you know 12 13
just [__] sucking well i also
remember for maybe like the first five
or six cigarettes i ever smoked was just
like puffing but i remember the first
time i inhaled oh it was like
it's a game changer oh yeah well how
about the dark side
do you think this is trash i know how
kevin feels about this when you were
smoking yeah do you think it's garbage
that if you're going out to like a nice
meal you got a few people you're going
out you're gonna do appetizers you're
gonna do dessert you're gonna do the
whole nine yards so you think it's
trashy that like after a couple drinks
and the apps before dinner gets there
you sneak out and have a bernie and come
back not even sneak out like i'm gonna
go and have a cigarette and come back no
you think that's trash no no i like that
i think i think i think it's classy as
[__]
class it's i mean it's not classy yeah i
mean if it's got to be if i got if it it
could only be categorized as clash or
trash
if there's no middle ground
i do lean a little bit more towards
class there you go
gentlemen get them out of here this
guy's just crazy just just southern
gentleman over here something like yeah
like there's something about just like i
guess the way i grew up looking at
smoking it's always looked cool
it's up there too with stopping by when
you have a table stopping by the bar on
the way back in and doing a shot and
having a drink with your boy whoever
you're at to dinner with shots no that's
true that's classy too
let's grab a drink
you go to the bathroom you bang a van
just keeps going like find the vein
between your toes you know get out of
here
you know
on the on the ride home you stop over
whack a guy you know he's just giving
out information you have a nice dinner
yeah
wait the um i mean i don't know dude
like i guess it depends on how you're no
you know what he thinks it's garbage if
you you're in a place an establishment
if you're in a restaurant it's ignorant
or rude to leave and then come back in
he thinks no well listen we would go out
like we would this is what happened
we'll go to a diner right
and at diner i get the rules at the new
york city diner very you know
loosey-goosey yeah yeah sure sure you
got post up for three days if you wanted
people do people pay rent questions are
you supposed to do yeah but he if me and
him go out we have lunch
and then he wants both of us
to go outside and smoke us leave the
table go outside smoke a cigarette and
then come back in and sit like we're
already done eating
that to me i got the bust of smoke we'll
be right back
you've left the table
that then that then ends the affair you
might come back in you might yeah we're
going to have some coffee let's try it
out
see the dessert menu this is interesting
because i cause that whack a guy i see
that i i gotta say i still lean class
see i still leave this is a [__]
setup for something what about you
buttons
kippy is so right you guys are psychos
thank you if more people would be doing
it when you got up and go to dinner not
everybody's getting up they're [__]
sitting at their table you're going to
leave your nice meal to stand on the
sidewalk
you're telling me all right maybe we're
over at gallagher's maybe we're having a
nice time maybe we're having a couple of
drinks we're relaxing we just had some
[__] appetizers some crab cakes we're
waiting on the steaks they're clearing
off you want to go out and bust the
smoke real quick yeah let's go that
doesn't sound nice i see you smiling
from here to eat pizza oh i'm smiling
because i'm laughing no yeah then you
come in smell like an ashtray and the
table next to you it's it's animalistic
that's the worst yes three dudes all
went out and smoked maybe okay maybe i
was a little off on i i thought it meant
you meant like after [__]
before the meal
that's bordering after the meal i'm with
you i'm saying in between at the table
you're going back to the table to finish
dinner i think it would have to be after
dinner
between post post between drinks and
dessert
that i can make i think you got to eat
you got to do the meal first thank you
wow yeah and then you have a little
espresso yeah a little shot of espresso
you like me step out have a smoke and
you're gonna be classy about it gonna
have a smoke he's gonna have an
old-fashioned i'm gonna have a voucher
you know they'll be waiting for you when
you get back you come you go outside and
you gotta be and you gotta be classy
smoking not hot boxing yeah yeah yeah
yeah you gotta be out there coming you
can't have like your head out the door
like no i'll be right back no no you
gotta be out there [__] you gotta you
gotta you gotta get a cigarette holder
sitting in a carriage yeah a trench coat
or something you know a nice pea coat
something all right i'd be telling the
door guy a story
hey moe how you doing
yeah 20 years i've been coming here you
believe that
exactly that's pretty good
but i think it also depends where you
are if you go to like a very nice
[__] state smith and malinsky or
whatever i think that's okay but if
you're doing it an applebee's or
something that's a bad look that just
shows that well some people applebee's
is smith and lewinsky's i happen to be
one of them yeah no i'm a big applebee's
man myself i like to stretch it out at
the dinner if i gotta go if i gotta go
uh if i gotta go chain if i gotta go if
i gotta go times square restaurant which
is going to categorize you going i gotta
go tgi fridays oh yeah of course i'm
gonna turn ggi friday guys in that
regard they've
you do have a vibe that you would walk
into a friday's and the staff would be
stoked and it would be on tuesday
i feel like sean can order off menu at a
tgi friday you're wearing one of their
old uniforms
have you ever got can you say with
certainty that you've ever 100 gotten
hammered at a chain spotlight [__] yeah
dude where was elegance
is that a breakfast place
but no better it's a furniture store
but all right bennigan's dude actually i
can i can [__] tell you when it was
the year two thousand it was
january 2008 right i'm in a car with i
can't remem kenny's sibling house do you
guys know that guy no comedian he was on
xm radio for a while we were doing a
[__] we're doing shows down in south
carolina we're driving back we're
somewhere in
north carolina and the giants were
playing the green bay packers
for the nfc championship that year right
and in the car with us was this dude
named tom mccaffrey who was like a
massive giants fan so he made us pull
over
at the first place we could bennigan's
to
yeah and i got like i got unexpected you
know when you like oop oh yeah i did get
[__] up those are the best we were
like oh i'm shit-faced then all you have
to do is get back in the car
five more hours oh that's awesome yeah
yeah but i didn't have to drive luckily
of course pee a lot
if there was a radiator hose just into
the back seat like i got you guys that
would have been heavy no antifreeze
issues
kept let's talk about black buffalo
black buff hello folks you ever find
yourself out there on the prairie or the
range
and you're at a challenge
at a dip
reach for a little black buffalo i'm
telling you it's a nicotine dip
alternative
that's absolutely fantastic yeah we got
a lot of people who dip out there chew
long cuts pouches switch over switch
over if you're 21 or over and you dip or
chew tobacco pouches are long cut you
have to try this alternative black
buffalo black buffalo is everything you
love about dipping including the
nicotine just without the actual tobacco
stem or leaf it's a good substance to go
you know hey you know if you don't want
to get all completely off try every
other time you know what i mean lighten
the load a bit uh they sell their
products at blackbuffalo.com it's
available in both long clap pouches plus
if you're looking to ditch nicotine and
tobacco completely tap into their
nicotine free options called xero my
favorite part about this product right
here boys
born in the midwest raised in the south
u-s-a black buffalo proudly manufactures
their products right here in the u.s of
a they've sent us to us i take it gives
you a little whoo gives a little
pick-me-up you know what i mean nice
good stuff smooth and crispy yes uh so
it's a new year if you're one of the 10
million people who are 21 and over and
dip tobacco consider turning over a new
leaf by switching to black buffalo head
to blackbuffalo.com use promo code
garbage at checkout for 25 off your
first order that's the best offer you're
gonna find around these parts but you
have to use our code garbage for 25
percent you're off your first order one
last time that's promo promico garbage
for 25 off your first order warning this
product contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical kip i want to talk
about all form is that a helix i want to
ask you a question that's what i heard
now listen helix has been killing the
bachelor's top-notch outfit a long time
you take the quiz we know the drill but
i heard a rumor over there at
headquarters that now they're getting
into the sofa game it's quick it's easy
they're comfortable they're durable
they're reliable
and it's called all forms all form baby
you can customize your couch your sofa
love seat this is true this is true
buddy they were bonkos like we said the
the good folks over there all form slash
helix uh sent us a couch it's right over
there t-bone's sitting on it lunch in it
no big deal feet on the couch by the way
um your room clean
[Laughter]
i'm gonna take away your playstation
yeah get upstairs and get your homework
done uh they sent it to us i put it
together stop looking at your sister i
put it together myself it's easy peasy
everything snaps in screws in
you can create the different whatever
pillows you want color fabric it's comfy
man finishes the whole nine yards so
it's good couch
check it out all uh
all form uh has an e they offer forever
warranty which is literally forever
financing flexible payment plan so a
sofa is never far away to find the
perfect sofa go to allforeign.com
garbage and they're offering 20 off
orders for our listeners at allforum.com
garbage 20 talk of 5 10 15 20
off all orders for our listeners all
form.com garbage not back to the show
yeah but yeah i would love to do to set
aside like a proper thursday yeah all
right go hit a nice tgi fridays
applebee's something like that at happy
hour what about a red lobster
uh it's not really a cool bar scene at
the red lobster all right i could point
maybe maybe we'll go there for dinner
filled with fishermen yeah
but go to like a like a like a like a
suburban town and go to like a classic
have a classic friday's happy hour
experience get all the appetizers yeah
we should do this all the fun signature
drinks yeah get hammered on like my ties
and blue wines yeah i open a trim dude
when i was when i was like in in like
the year 2000 i worked at
nothing is sadder than a wannabe chain
restaurant oh
you know what i mean they're just trying
to they're like just like you know yeah
picking and choosing like they got they
got the t-shirts you could buy the goofy
hats they got they got the crazy [__]
the wacky [__] like the greeting when
you walk in yeah um they're wearing
they've got spenders and [__] i worked
at i'm not going to say the name of the
place but the name of the place was
portobello's
what's going
portobello's baton rouge louisiana uh
and guess what in the portobello's the
apostrophe in portobellos because it was
possessive not plural right sure was
a portabella that's pretty good get the
[__] out of here yeah the last name yeah
no portobellos like the it was a
portobello mushroom and the mushroom is
the apostrophe which is very
fried it's very i don't know i like it
that [__] that that graphic designer
must have been a descendant of leonardo
da vinci he was like
but it had i remember the big thing that
used to drive me [__] crazy was at
happy hour
every day that every it was a margarita
special
italy it's like the mexico of uh europe
you're like that's not no one's ever
said that did they have non-italian
dishes like do they have like a crab dip
no it wasn't choked it was all but it
was all like italian it was like a
prosciutto poppers and [__] like that
you know i don't have it sean i want to
be on your side because you're a guest
his place is checking out but i'm a
portobello's man
right now they [__] went hard in the
paint but there was only one location
well yeah that's yeah that's a lot of
branding for one location just one you
know franchise is available
yeah um
i do love i grew like i said i've said a
bunch i've grew up on the applebee's the
fridays and there is just something a
couple of samplers and some coronas
let's go um
i was at college basketball and they got
15 tvs in there yeah yeah yeah i was in
the middle of like minnesota on a
on the road and we stopped at a tgi or
we stopped at an applebee's and i don't
think it was like
buy like corporate didn't sign off on
this
oh it's like a rogue it was like 50 cent
margaritas on a wednesday and i'm like
well i am bored
it was crazy i mean what else what would
you say is the rushmore is it applebee's
tgi fridays applebee's tgi fridays
[__] i respect what you're both saying
but i can tell you the correct answer
okay here we go it's all of them at
different times they all rise and they
fall they all have
peak five years peak six years remember
how hot chili's was with the baby back
ribs that's when they were killing it
they were killing it they were rising
all right
telling me chili's
comes anywhere close to tgi friday at a
certain time they did they had the hot
hand they had the hot end i like two
minutes of fame do you understand what
i'm saying i like how you're pitching
this like
season of ending of law or like finale
of loss
version of like they were all at
different times on the mount rushmore
they were they all had their moments
just like dominoes had their moment
pizza at their moment little seasons at
their moment but i'm talking okay but i
that's crazy that you're so against
chili's because i would put chili's uh
on the rush chili's is [__] come on
you're that's a classy operation
crazy
i mean i feel like
i'm not saying i don't eat pepper they
got the pepper they got the nice brand
thing i don't i don't the baby once
again the baby back ribs i want my baby
every batch i mean come on everybody was
singing that yeah man singing it yeah no
one's eating parole officers and judges
we're singing that in court who i mean
who but who what else what's there
i can't tji friday's had a [__] huge
but tgi fridays applebee's chili's but
what's the [__] outback steakhouse up
there
there you go there it is thank you
i'm sorry i've been i have bonefish
grill now that's real popular but that's
right that's fine
that's fine if you talk to my mother
that's fine dining okay
my mom 100 they have tilapia there i'm
talking about places that are at
like slidell louisiana and every like
major suburb 30 minutes outside of a
major city what big four and you nailed
it yeah it's outback chilis
i would lose chilis and put pizza hut up
there as a dining establishment you
can't go this guy wow i really hate some
chili chilis are you hearing this
corporate you can't get a drink at pizza
hut yeah you used to be able to what in
the [__] could you get a cake you could
get it you gotta get it get it just go
get beers
get one from the truck driver who's got
a six-pack
waiting on his phone
in the back
what do you got in the file cabinet
downstairs you couldn't get a beer at
pizza huh my pizza you for sure could
get there was a draft beer thing yes
really 100
i think that was off i think that was
not sanctioned either yeah
i think that was a rogue because of
pizza huts
you ever you ever see some spellings of
some restaurants where you're like i
wish they would have consulted a better
english oh yeah yeah i see it in where i
live in astoria i see you know you walk
to the store or whatever and you look
and you think not to be a dick but you
look and you're like you thought that
was gonna work whatever it was something
like that like what what were you
thinking
dude you sunk everything you had into
this dude
okay burritos what are you
i love astoria queens because it's like
an it's like an open mic for first-time
business owners
i mean
that is so true that
is
so good
there is a hope and a prayer man they're
just going you want to try to nail salon
yeah
you got 15 minutes on pedicures getting
all right a nail salon slash rock
climbing studio yeah it's somewhere in
astoria on my block there's a taco slash
pizza place yeah
yeah that's big that's easy
our nail salon that uh my girl gets like
uh you know her mayonnaise and pettis
it's connected to a uh juice bar that
they put in recently yeah they just cut
a little corner out and stuck a juice
bar in it that's big in new york selling
like nails and [__] yeah you can rent
the juice bar in a place it's like
you're in there like juice bar for rent
and you're like what get out of here
yeah so you remember laser tag
i mean i'm sorry i forgive me for asking
such redundant questions
such rhetorical [__] questions yeah
personal attacks
you guys don't know knight riders
laser tag kind of i was in the service
sean yeah
dude i mean laser tag was fun as [__]
but it's sort of faded but you know what
the new like have you been to an escape
room yet there's one there's one across
the street or next door i can't i have
such a i have such a a
pre-judgment on it
it feels very um
uh jim and pam to me very very very
workplace going out and doing something
team building well it's also like it's
also like it's no if you if you can't
figure your way out just ride the clock
out and yeah they're going to come get
you there's no statement there's another
group coming in there like if there were
if there was actually you've done it
yeah yeah i did it in new orleans like
if you actually had to sign a waiver
listen if you don't get out of here in
60 minutes there will be poison gas
filling the mausoleum spice up a
thursday huh
like really put some [__] pressure
for sure or like that's the thing i
think allen and accounting got a spear
to the neck
he signed out he signed off on it but
it's like you're in like the mausoleum
or the crypt or like the it's like if i
actually stumbled upon a dungeon i would
be like this is kind of interesting
let's hang out like see like i want to
come back you got a black light and a tv
in there give me some like real work
like my like thanksgiving with your
sister's in-laws yeah you got to
navigate that get out of that situation
the handsy uncle yeah a really
complicated escape room that would be
pretty cool like one where it's actual
[__] you wanted to not be involved in
almost like tony and tina's wedding
meets an escape room i guarantee i
guarantee in astoria right now is an
escape room wedding chapel
if you could get through these life
situations
yeah
that's perfect
oh very good all right we got more
questions yeah of course of course of
course um let's see this is from stanley
ever put cold cuts in a taco shell every
single day of my life no not in a while
but [__] you you've done that and i want
to emphasize the shell part the the the
hard shell oh [__] yeah dude roast beef
in a hard shell i've never thought of it
but it sounds fantastic can i say this
about them yeah all right i don't know
if it was my mom put them in the oven
too long or whatever
i never really had a good home kit taco
shell you're taking that dude they never
did i would just try to have that [__]
in a bowl with some [__] tortilla
chips on it some fresh tostitos i'd
rather have the taco salad well taco
salad is is superior
yes but i okay so growing up dressing uh
i'm kind of spoiled on cold cuts because
my dad
has a catering uh
business remember yeah right so like all
my life we never had like oscar mayer or
anything he would just
carve it but i mean it was you know
bring it home and bring it home so like
not boar's head but whatever the
equivalent of borders you had your
access to own to your own deli counter
pretty much i mean my dad would just
bring [__] home whenever
grocery time pretty good yeah but it
also meant you were eating a lot of like
hey so we're gonna eat shrimp shrimp uh
pasta for the next three days yeah
yeah it came like a five gallon jug oh
because well because you know the
hibernia bank grand opening expected 250
and they only got 180. so you know we
got two panzers there's a lot of
meatballs and mashed potatoes coming
your way dude a lot of swedish meatballs
growing up
ain't nothing wrong with it nothing
wrong the i mean dude if there is if
there is the the best way to make
something seem classy that's not classy
at all swedish meatballs yeah yeah it's
like
yeah yeah 100 but god do i [__] love
them give me the two all i need is one
toothpick i'll make it last let's go
yeah for sure everybody gets their own
color color-coded toothpick all that
stuff is fantastic we were talking about
that yesterday we were [__] on kfc
because he makes sometimes at home he
just makes little uh pigs in a blanket
but he home makes them for dinner he
home makes them for dinner he'll get
like that but who the um kevin clancy
over at barcelona
yeah
he makes his own little little crescent
hot dog jones dude he gets the crescent
rolls and then the hot dog but which
iris i do respect it but as a whole i
need a potpourri i need to have that
with the swedish meatballs with the
spinach balls with the little slices of
uh this that and the other thing i'd
like to have all the hors d'oeuvres for
dinner you're like a jackson pollock
or nerfs
smatter it everywhere and just observe
that's all puffs be inspired i love
those little puffs oh those little puffs
but you get uh you get a you get a roast
beef in a pan you put a little that
roast beef gravy get that [__] real hot
your microwave the ortega bam hot roast
beef tacos come on what are you putting
on top of it nothing really we're all
dogging it i like that yeah i like that
i mean i i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be
i'm not gonna pull punches here on
anybody like myself included like that
sort of eating is my favorite sort of
food pretty good i don't even know what
you call it like assassin style or yeah
makeshift
single dad yeah
single dad we're just like i gotta get
creative here what do i got i am
switching back more to finding the joys
of the grocery store oh yeah because
we've been we've been ordering way too
much and all that stuff i am i am
finding the the it is a different kind
of joy a fresh loaf of bread some
[__] lunch meat a fresh thing of mayo
oh yeah a couple nice slices of tomato a
fresh bag of chips new pickles i mean
dude it doesn't get much better than
that dude you know what there should be
aren't you on a diet what are we doing
we're talking about we described a four
thousand calories i'm on a financial
diet
saving money here you get what i'm
saying there should be a gruel
restaurant what's gruel like a gruel is
just a word for just like a like if you
mix like beans oh yeah [__] slice hot
dogs and crush up some doritos in there
you know but like that dude a girl you
just walk in you're like yeah god give
me the hangover and it's just you know
just uh eggs mixed with
chili yeah you know
dirtbag bowls
oh my god i'd live at this place that
would be pretty good this is perfect
this is from paco uh
have you ever been to a small fast food
chain in your city and been able to
order mac and cheese with chopped up hot
dogs in it there's a place
in uh tucson called eg's that has craft
macaroni and cheese with chopped up hot
dogs in it
which
i feel like i would order just you know
you're in the neighborhood you got to
try it i'm stopping by i don't know what
to tell you there's a there's a novelty
i know i've shown my fat really bad over
the last couple of minutes but this
question wasn't the one that was going
to redeem me
drop a pin in that on google maps
i feel like i feel like there's um
i think there's a spot there's like a
new orleans has a couple of like here
you'd call them bodegas but there
they're just like stores you know but
they're just little [__]
exactly just think about the bodegas if
you don't know what bodega is just take
like a 7-eleven but it's lo it's there's
only one other license yeah
throw a couple of cats in there and they
have exactly and they have a lot of beer
and they have a deli counter right
because there's a it's a place in new
orleans called verde mart in the lower
french quarter that's amazing i'm pretty
sure they used to do a macaroni and
cheese with spam
that sounds awesome and that [__] they
also
this is kind of a not a plug but an
advertisement in a way like they do a
sandwich there called an all that jazz
which is
you know uh po boy bread uh uh turkey
ham hot all this hot turkey ham bacon
shrimp
three types of cheeses and like a like a
thousand island-esque dressing
and tomatoes what are you doing to me
blows your [__] dick in half rock
hard over here but like i was home over
the holidays and i was out with you know
friends and family and everybody went
home before me and that's my problem
when i drink i just want to [__] stay
out all goddamn night sure so i was out
by myself for a little bit and i
stumbled to verdi mart and i go this is
such a new orleans experience i was like
uh let me get all that jazz it's like 3
30 in the morning you know can't get all
that jazz and the woman behind the count
goes
baby i ain't got the energy to make that
for you tonight i'm sorry
it's like i'm making anything else half
off what you want and i like laugh i'm
like it's fine i'm like what's easy i
could make you a chicken cut the pool
boy i'm like that's great that's great
so she's working on that and i'm i'm
grabbing like a bag of chips and i'm
going to the counter
and uh this [__] old ass dude walks
in grabs like a 24-ounce course
puts it on and they're like mickey you
know you can't pay for that mickey you
know you ain't got no money that's the
woman the other one behind the couch
like mickey you know you ain't got no
money he can't pay for that and he's
talking basic drunk gibberish and these
there's guys like that everywhere
there's old drunks and i was like what
is it what's what's i got it and i paid
for his any like gibberish thank you you
know it's like you know happy you know
merry christmas whatever
and he leaves and i'm paying for my
stuff and then the woman comes over my
sandwich like i made you i made you one
anyway because you took care of mickey i
was like what oh man that's heartwarming
yeah that is she made me want anyway but
then i was like it didn't seem like it
took that long yeah exactly you made it
the same amount of time yeah
but whatever thank you
yeah dude you gotta always buy always
buy the drunk guy a drink
that's like a motto i live by like if
you've got an extra dollar 20 and a guy
wants a [__] sometimes they get mad
at you though because they don't want
the guy coming around sometimes yeah i
guess that's a good if he's a problem
it's like don't be giving him that
because then he's going to come hanging
out looking for you again yeah yeah i
know i noticed like what i'm about to
say
it's like it sounds like i'm trying to
like sound like a good person but i have
a soft spot where i always give i try
and always [__] give especially like
guys in my neighborhood who i see sure i
try and always break them off some but
like my girlfriend has a point she's
like half those dudes aren't even
actually homeless yeah because you see
them they're wearing fresh nikes and
it's funny yeah because there's one lady
that collects change right by the uh
the queensborough bridge and i just want
to open the door every time i drive by
her because i know she's doing that she
does she's not homeless yeah just doing
it as a hustle there's a dude who does
the windows that way i always break off
when i see him not even for a window
just give him a buck or whatever yeah
come stop to the red light but you know
this lady you know this lady's face i
see her i just go
because you know she just
taking it which if she's brutal she just
gives you like this really sad like like
pathetic face but i know she's hustling
everybody but there's also you see
you're walking around regularly between
a new york drunk and an and a new
orleans drama oh yeah yeah it's like
totally cause they're like culturally
wet brain down there and it's like nice
wet brain
culture well they're like you're falling
off stools betting on turtle races and
[__] oh dude chicken drops dude what's a
chicken what's a chicken drop chicken
drop i mean this happens more in like
north than this like people forget that
like new orleans is here and then 30 40
miles north is mississippi
right so in between there's there's bars
that do chicken drops which is
it's a bar you walk in there on the
floor is a grid drawn into the floor
with numbers all over it uh everybody
places numbers on the bets on the
numbers and they put out a chicken and
whichever number the chicken shits on
that person wins the kitties
the chicken drop baby is there food in
there too oh i sure have everything in
there dude
we used to do uh bet on the gumball that
would come out it was like the you would
be at the bar get all boozed up
and you're looking for some action you
know every bar is a gumball machine in
it
also i like i like how it's like oh yeah
gumball
chicken turds yeah
[Laughter]
with a gumball
we used to play a little game in polo i
would love that dude if i walked into a
bar and you're betting on where a
chicken shits [__] sign me
i want to buy shares in the place not
talking about gumballs here we're
talking about feces god damn it yeah i'm
saying i like the action i want it i
like it i like the action come on i mean
they should do that with a human at this
point just a blo just blindfold the guy
i feed him a bunch of x-lacs and just
run out there and just all right spin
him around wherever he [__] blasts
that'd be awesome like why wasn't that
in squid games you know
like i [__] up hunger games that would
be great just for entertainment
yeah whoops a daisy that was a coffee
belch
but yeah wet brain that's such a
that's such a that is such a great way
to say it dude yeah there's i mean every
city i get what you're saying like yeah
but like you know guys who like probably
a lot of them came back from nam and
[__] and just started drinking and never
stopped yeah or like you know maybe not
even that but like yeah those guys are
like oh man you haven't been sober in
35 years yeah you need this little nip
to like keep going straighten that guy
out yeah yeah yeah then you got your
sandwich and i got to do all that jazz
baby i highly recommend if you're ever
in the city verde mart
all that jazz you talk about garbage
gone right
good stuff see good garbage garbage hole
in the wall placing a really good
sandwich at 3 30 in the morning and hop
on homeless guy good garbage top notch
murdering the homeless guy out front
because you didn't get the sandwich bad
garbage with the sandwich you got
instead beating him he got beat to death
i got a [__] cutlet for you
all right let's do a couple more now we
got a wrapper up um it's been a food
heavy one uh this one
ever put uh ever put shredded cheese on
a sandwich like you had you didn't have
the slice [__] slice of american
cheese or cheddar cheese or swiss cheese
yeah and all you have is like the yeah
the three blend mexican shredded cheese
the taco mix yeah dude what's this guy
with what's this guy with his softballs
here
you're coming to me with this [__]
there is nothing more
better of a value than shredded cheese
wait is this guy wait what's his name tj
that stand for training wheels jackson
this [__] guy with these questions
you're playing with the big boys now dj
have i ever put shredded cheese on a
sandwich i ran out of crap singles what
do you want from me
hungry kids here i feel like you were
about to launch into a recipe you came
up with yeah you were you had something
on the in the hopper
just now what you were like the shredded
cheese you put it you were like
you're getting oh you're getting poetic
here
you don't get a better value than the
shredded there's always so much cheese
left over after you make tacos or you
use the bag of shredded cheese of course
it's there for weeks yeah you gotta use
it i tend to i tend to if that is if i'm
cooking and that's my only option is the
shredded cheese i tend to try to make
something where i meld it you know what
i mean you melt some eggs melted
[Laughter]
be tender yeah
yeah yeah shredded cheese and eggs it
melts in there like butter oh man it's
great you don't have to put a lid on it
or nothing but they don't make american
shredded cheese and that's the problem
with the country these days but i tell
you wrong
that you can't do american because it
sticks together i've never seen it they
don't i think they i don't think they do
i want to i'm going to flip i'm going to
flip this question on a couple guys from
philadelphia dude all right
because
[__] straight cheese you ever put you
ever put whiz on a sandwich dude oh yeah
of course yeah i used to [__] take
cheese cheese was in the jar he did as a
fat kid heat it up and just dip like
pretzels and crackers like just [__]
drinks you're talking about it looks
like a little mustard jar it's called
cheese whiz
it was like orange and yellow i'm
talking about the [__] that they put on
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah we might have we used to keep a jar
of it in the house dude can i tell you
my how excited the first time i ever
went to philadelphia and i didn't know
going in but the first time they were
like you want wiz or yeah the first time
i the the the the i i knew that i was
that obese person in my past life
because i was like
the level of excitement of like you're
gonna put [__] cheese whiz on a
sandwich love it love it give it to me
isn't that illegal man what are you
doing i don't want to get in trouble man
welcome can we do this
is this allowed i don't even care yeah
did you have from the catering company
did you guys have like would you have
like huge things of ice cream and this
and that i'd imagine you would my whole
[__] life dude my dad there like all
every girl like it was all just
somebody's wedding cake on your birthday
congratulations julia yeah i like i can
cook really well but only for like 50 to
100 people
you know what i mean
like jerry stiller i like it yeah dude
it's like [__] that's so funny you
grow up you grow up just what i was you
got a communion party you need i got you
well dude like i used to split time
after school between my grandma's house
and my dad's actual go to the actual
business which was just the house that
he grew up in they turned it into the
actual business
right so
it depended on which like half the week
i go to my grandma's half the week i'd
go there and if i was in trouble i had
to go there because i couldn't hang out
with friends and [__] but i used to go i
used to [__] go into the walk-in
cooler and i would just spoon feed
myself caviar i didn't realize
caviar i love that [__] damn but i would
just because i would just go in there
when i was hungry and just be like i
don't know what [__] no celery and uh
did you ever get caught your daddy i
have something like talking about black
lives matter
expensive yes when he caught me spoon
feeding caviar i was like what the [__]
are you doing
what like it's just it's just salty dip
because it's soaked i love caviar still
to this [__] about a kid with a [__]
high profile palette over here
i wouldn't go near that when i was a kid
now i [__] crave it well i didn't
know what it was though i just was like
trying it i like i think i actually
dipped the frito in it
it was like
holy [__] it was like
hooked and it was
like
weeks just this one jar i would just
hide behind all the rest and [__]
your dad's going over the books at the
end of the month we're losing money i
can't believe yeah
i used to spoon feed myself cold caviar
and then drink warm diet or warm cokes
it's all right there's a bite to a warm
coke that you can't find anywhere else
on this planet but every once in a while
it's really good a warm coconut really
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah
taste i i still maintain when i
when i used to smoke when i was a
hardcore stoner as a kid but still a
cold can of coke went high
[__] it oh yeah simple pleasures it's
right it's the mana it's manna in your
mouth and not man manna but if you're
into man in your mouth it's that as well
it's just as good it's good [__] ladies
and gentlemen
sean patton as we said brand new album
out oh yeah king scorpio filming a brand
new special tip patina's down there in
new orleans february 3rd doing two shows
you want to go see him he's absolutely
fantastic i know you guys know that but
i'm telling you anyway go to me sean
patton.com get yourself some dicks do
yourself a [__] favor what else you
got coming up you're out on the road i'm
just out on the road dates are all there
on the site uh i'm not you know i'm
trying not to think too much past the
third because i just want to
you know it's the first official special
and i've been doing this quite a while
so it's like it's exciting it's going to
be a hard time thank you yeah
but you know i'm always on the road i'm
always just check the site
follow me on instagram at mr sean patton
and yeah [__] you know i'm out there
let's do it love it love you buddy love
it
give me what you got for them uh our
tour dates are on sale now the link will
be in the description check me out at
cameron comedy on all social media and
watch your special
spread the word gang we love you t-bone
love you buddy we'll see you next week
peace